all right one last method for you and
big credit to susie for being the one
who thought of this method i think it's
a delightful solution path so let's have
a look at it together um the key piece
of knowledge that we're going to use
here is not algebraic manipulation or um
you know the the kind of different forms
of the complex numbers that we were
manipulating before which was the key in
our different solutions this time what
we're going to do is try and employ our
knowledge of vectors because you can
think of this as a 2d vector problem and
to sort of wrap our head around the
geometry here and uh you know work out
what are the perspectives that are going
to help us solve this question prove
this result together so here's the way
it works i'm going to think about this
sort of situation here with zero
u i'll just do that in like a lower case
here and then v
up here we're going to think of these
not so much as different numbers or we
will think of them as numbers but
primarily i'd like to think of them as
points on the complex plane and
therefore you join two points together
you get a vector and it's important as
well that you think about the direction
that you're joining those two points in
so for example if i called you know the
complex number u if it was represented
by the point a and we took the complex
number v and represented that with the
point b
as an example
uh o to a is different to a to o when we
were thinking about these just as
complex numbers direction doesn't really
you know this way or that way doesn't
matter as much uh in terms of you know
being able to think about this one
little interval here but um o a and ao
are actually opposite to each other and
that's going to be quite important in
this proof so let's have a think about
how to conceive of this
what i think is going to be most helpful
is to actually take a single object in
this geometric scenario and look at it
from two different perspectives uh you
can do this a bunch of different ways
but i think the most helpful one is
going to be this side of the equilateral
triangle over here you could think of it
as a b but i'm actually going to and
you're going to see why this is in a
second i think it's going to be more
easy for us to work with if we actually
think of it as b a so you can see i've
got that arrow there indicating
direction so i'm starting up here at b
and i'm going down to a
now in terms of this vector b a i can
think about it in a couple of different
ways and because i can think about it or
define it in a couple of different ways
those two perspectives if they both shed
light on the same object those two
perspectives we can equate with each
other and much like say comparing
coefficients when we're doing you know
polynomials partial fractions
that comparison from two different
perspectives will yield insight and
allow us to solve what's going on so
what's the first way we can think about
uh b
b
a this vector here and i'm just gonna
sort of uh i'll write it like so b a
okay well the first thing is let's zoom
out and i'll shuffle this over so i've
got a bit of space to actually write
over here i can think about ba as an a
pair of vectors that are added together
and concatenated together or do one
after the other
line up heads and tails and just kind of
string them together can you see in this
situation
what two vectors i need to add up so how
can i consider this as a vector addition
problem
to equal b a right have a think about
this for a second
by vector addition i can think of vector
b a as any string of vectors that start
from b and end up at a of course i can
just go directly there b a but i can
actually also take this kind of long
scenic route from b via the origin over
to a and the reason why this is going to
be useful is will help us relate to the
actual complex numbers u and v that are
hiding underneath our points a and b
so in this case if i'm starting over at
b and i want to end up at a then the
first step to go by the origin is go b
to o
and then o to a that'll be my set of
steps right so again please note the
direction here i'm going from b down
toward the origin and then i'm going to
go from the origin over to a so if i you
know string this vector after this
vector then you're going to get the
desired result so just so i can
distinguish this let me just put a color
on this there you go so we'll highlight
that in purple
so i'm going to go
b
o
and then i'm going to add o
a does that make sense and this is the
uh this is that highlighted vector vr
which is going to be crucial in a minute
okay so once i've got this the reason
why this is useful is because if the
complex number v
represents going up to b from o to b
doing that uh translation as it were
then if i'm going to do b to o that's
the same as doing v in the opposite
direction it's minus v right so
therefore instead of writing i'm going
to convert this into complex numbers
instead of writing b o i can write that
as minus v
and in much the same way but more
straightforward o a that vector there is
just in a straightforward way
represented by the complex number u so i
can write that as plus
u and i guess it'd be a bit more
sensible to write that
subtraction in order that doesn't put
the negative first so i'm going to say
ba equals u take away v okay
so that's the first perspective on ba
what's another perspective that we can
use well remember this question has told
us that 0 u and v they form an
equilateral triangle and the properties
of equilateral triangles can be very
useful to us and we're going to use them
in a second so what i'm going to say is
since this triangle aob
is equilateral
how can i take advantage of this fact
well i can say lots of things about it
but the thing that's going to be most
useful to me in sort of manipulating
these vectors is that i've got an angle
of pi on 3 in every single one of the
corners it's an equilateral triangle so
all the angles are the same now this
angle here or rather this vector here b
a i can think of it as the same as
vector b o but rotated by pi on three
radians and this is important
anti-clockwise think about this right if
you think of this pi on 3 radians angle
up here and you can see it going from
this vector bo and the direction is
preserved you can see it starts from b
radiates out toward o then it radiates
out toward a you can see the hand of the
clock as it were being turned back
anti-clockwise pi on three radians and
that's really important often when
people are doing a vector reasoning like
this they get their anti-clockwise and
they're clockwise you know confused so
therefore what i can say is since aob is
equilateral going back to
that vector b a
i can think of it as that same vector we
started with b o this one over here but
instead of adding on
vector o a so that addition there which
took us um down here and then towards
here i can just think of this vector and
do the rotation what is the arithmetic
uh in complex number land that and sort
of is equivalent to this vector rotation
right the geometric operation and the
answer is because it's going in the
right direction anti-clockwise i just
need to multiply by um a vector of one
unit i don't wanna make it longer or
shorter b o and b a are equivalent in in
length but i want to rotate it around
by pi on three radians so this is the
complex number that has the same
magnitude sorry a magnitude of one so it
doesn't stretch out or shorten my uh my
b o vector
but it rotates it in that anti-clockwise
direction okay so i hope you can see
that equivalence there it's where i've
drawn them in the same color
okay now the thing is i can actually say
like i mentioned before this bo is equal
to minus v and then that's multiplied by
e to the i pi on three okay so what i've
got here and i'll just highlight here in
blue one here and one here i have two
alternative ways to say b a right these
must be equal to each other because
they're both the same vector right so
i'm therefore going to conclude
therefore
minus v
e to the i pi on 3.
what that must be equal to is u take
away v looking at my two blue stars
there right so you can see me sort of
getting that one result
out of these two things here here is uh
i'm just going to put these down here
like so so i hope you can see the
logical connection there
okay now we're almost ready you can see
here i've got this equation here which i
know doesn't quite look like it but this
is going to be the bedrock in fact it's
so important i'm going to give it a name
let's call this equation 1. this is
going to be the bedrock to get us to the
result we were trying to prove so i just
need one last piece of the puzzle which
is to be able to get like see how this
is all in terms of v's and u's except
for this one little pesky complex number
hanging out in there right so if i can
get that in terms of
u's and v's then i can make that
substitution and then i'll have an
equation that relates u and v and
hopefully i should be able to manipulate
that to get to the desired result that
i'm trying to prove so how do i do that
well i'm going to do this same trick
right i know that aob is equilateral so
this sort of clockwise rotation to get
from one vector to another by pi on
three radians i can do it as many times
as i like and it's it's going to enable
me to use this e to the i pi on three
relationship and substitute it for
something else okay so since i'm using
the same logic that i have an
equilateral triangle i'm just going to
say similarly and then i can relate this
u and this v in the same kind of pi on
three relationship that i saw before so
what color have i not used yet
i'll use i'll use i'm just going to pull
out a new color this is going to be
super colorful okay so this is pion3
here
and you can see again it's an
anti-clockwise rotation but notice
o-a-o-a is going to
retain anti-clockwise pine three radians
it's not going to turn into b0 it's
going to turn into o
b can you see me rotating around the
origin up here i rotate it around b
because that was the tail of the vector
here i'm rotating around the origin
because this is the tail of the vector
i've got a different reference point
okay
so by similar logic i can say the way to
get to angle or rather vector ob it's
the same purple vector but i'm looking
at it in reverse order it's the same as
o a
and then i'm multiplying by i'll use
orange like i said
it's the same transformation but i'm
getting it from a different spot
geometrically so that's why i'm trying
to highlight it in a different way
that's e to the i pi on three and now i
just need to substitute what are ob and
oa not in terms of vectors but in terms
of complex numbers so this is just going
to be v
this is u
and then i've got e to the i pi on 3
trailing on the end and remember what
was my goal here right what i was trying
to get was a way to substitute this e to
the i pi on 3
into here so that it's not in this this
equation 1 that i've written right so
all i need to do is to make e d i pion 3
the subject of this equation so i'm
going to divide through i'll put the e
the pine through on the left hand side
rather than the right hand side and
simultaneously i'm going to divide
through by u you can see that'll get
that over to the other side so i've got
v over u and let's call that
equation two all right
and now i'm ready to go we've done all
of this vector thinking and i'm that's i
can now put that to one side because the
vector thinking has enabled me to make
these um statements about the complex
numbers themselves and so
i'm going to substitute this result that
we just determined uh which i'm calling
equation two
i'm going to substitute it back into one
and then see what eventuates so let's
have a go
when i put in um when i write rather
this left hand side i start with the
minus v but instead of writing e to the
i pi over three this is the substitution
that i'm um
uh putting in here right so that's going
to be v over u
is that you're following so this is uh
this is this result that's just gone in
here so that's what's happening on the
left hand side the right hand side i
don't need to change very much it's you
take away v
and all i need to do is to blink and
you'll miss it multiply through by u
right if i multiply through by u i get
minus v squared on the left hand side on
the right hand side i get u squared
minus u
v and this is pretty much it right all i
need to do is to add a v squared uh onto
both sides
and i also need to
add a uv onto both sides to get them in
the right spots and that'll give me uv
equals u squared plus v squared and this
was the result i was trying to prove
so what i love about this method is that
it's still the same old scenario right
um we haven't changed this equilateral
triangle and the origin but we've
thought about it in a whole different
way is it longer or shorter i mean i i
think that's less important it's the
kind of vector thinking which i think is
so wonderful here there are going to be
other questions where even if this
method is longer than some of the other
methods we looked at before or more
complicated in terms of the algebra
there will be other questions that
demand this kind of manipulation of
vectors so i think it's really helpful
to wrap your head around how the the
logic of this fits so that you can use
it in other situations um you know you
want to be more flexible as flexible as
you can with all the tools in your
toolbox and the more you're used to
looking at the same problem but
attacking it from different angles and
using different methods
the more flexible you'll be able to
determine the most appropriate method
when you encounter a new problem